[Music]
whoo river babes we have so much to
discuss welcome to the Sweetwater
secrets preview show for episode two
22:33 shadow of a doubt I'm your host
Liana aguilera and I'm happy to say that
these serpents are back and in full
force this week so to celebrate I've got
my a leather jacket and in my mind I'm
kind of bringing you sweet P vibes today
although let's be real no one can rock a
turtleneck like Sweet Pea now today I'm
bringing you three clues that you
absolutely need to know before watching
this week's episode plus star Camilla
Mendez is dishing on Veronica's
complicated status with four parents
plus we are flashing back to a key scene
in Riverdale's first season that could
shed some light on how Cooper's
potential black hood motives but first
let's take a look at what you all had to
say in the comments about chapter xxxii
prisoners kicking things off with Yanina
her diya who wrote kisses for both Betty
and Veronica for getting things done and
being powerful strong women yes Queen
she also added hisses to Nick st. Claire
for existing I don't know what it is
about your face but I want to deliver
one of these right in your suck hole and
the new del woman added hisses to Nick
for ruining my idea that stubble makes
skies hotter Real Talk girl oh and that
reminds me can I also please add a
belated hiss to last week's episode what
the heck was with the whole I need to
make my bones thing listen up Archie in
Nick st. douche just cuz you keep saying
that phase with a really serious face
doesn't mean it makes any sense it's not
going to happen I'm glad I got that off
my chest
moving on you guys are really rockin my
world with your Charles Smith series now
Ellen Deveny said I could have sworn
that Charles Smith looked like hot dog
dude where are the dogs yes and Carlotta
feverishly agrees because she said the
real Charles is Benna she said that on
all caps so you know she's serious now I
would love this twist and I really
Miriam chica for posting identity theft
is not a joke chick millions of families
suffer every year as for your thoughts
on the black hood well the comments were
pretty much equally divided when it
comes to whether or not how Cooper is
the man under the mask now Madelaine ji
wrote I genuinely don't think that hell
is the black hood I just think it's too
obvious
okay on the flip side Elizabeth
Montgomery posted pal is never around
when Betty gets a call from the black
hood and if you look into the VHS eyes
they look just like house I can't argue
with you there girl
but then she boom added I still think
it's not hell he doesn't have any motive
plus he wouldn't torture his own
daughter like that also he's not that
gutsy and is a coward well I think it's
interesting that you bring that up
because I've been rewatching Riverdale's
first season for a super-secret project
that I'm working on more on that in just
a second and I came across this
insightful moment now take a look at
this flashback from episode six what do
you think I did did you kill Jason
blossom
you think that he has this stomach for
that now you guys what if hal was tired
of being viewed as weak what if he
became the black hood to prove to Alice
that he does have the stomach to step up
and take charge now I honestly have no
clue if that's why he's doing this but I
did think that it was an interesting
scene for us to revisit oh my god I
forgot about that part what do you think
hit the comments right now and tell me
and wrapping things up in this week's
comments Alou white posted I hope you do
this for season three oh well that's
very kind of you to say no you guys I've
had an absolute blast creating writing
and hosting Sweetwater secrets for all
you river babes I'm not quite sure about
next year just yet because I'm still
focusing on wrapping up season two but
if you'd like more sweet water in season
three share your thoughts with me in the
comments Kappa but for now I do want to
let you guys in on a little secret now
I've been working on a special new
project and I'll be spilling all the
details in the next few weeks but for
now here's what I can tell you I'm
currently working on a new show for the
summer that's focused on my favorite TV
couples and I know you guys are going to
love it because the first episode is
centered on Betty
and Jughead so if you're a bug head fan
I want you to hit the comments right now
and tell me why you love this couple and
share your favorite bug head scenes ask
me who's amazing now shifting back to
this week's episode we watched the promo
for episode 220 like 25 times
yeah things are getting crazy y'all
you're playing a very dangerous
Betty's gun is back there's a body bag
and it looks like V went shopping in
these lingerie closet and she looks
amazing you guys are not ready for this
speaking of Veronica I was oh so proud
of our raven-haired beauty for standing
up to her parents last week and here's
what Camila Mendez had to tell me about
Veronica's newfound mindset when it
comes to hiring in Miami I think
Veronica genuinely believes that she's
kind of the mediating mediator between
good and evil you know like she sees
that her parents are on this path and
she wants to try to get them to do
things in the purest way possible and
the only way she can do that is if she
has one foot in the dark and darkness
you know she's kind of being like a
secret agent yeah exactly Jenn but I add
up what I admire about Veronica I think
she's she's a professional and she's
she's ambitious and determined and I
think she kind of understands that her
mission statement comes with a price
yeah let's skip the pleasantries I have
your money
well we do know that V now has plenty of
cash but hopefully that price won't be
too expensive for her by the end of the
season and now it's time for your three
clues about episode 220 let's do this
number one get your remote ready for a
rewind because there's a blink and
you'll miss it moment that will leave
you particularly confused particularly
chick you're scaring me number two two
of the biggest questions from the
musical episode will be answered but
let's just say you won't want to sink
your teeth into the truth and number
three brace yourselves because this
episode will end with the bang in more
ways than one as in three three very
different kind of banks I got things now
check back with me after you watch
chapter 33 shadow of a doubt for a
bloody good Sweetwater secrets
after-show plus Lily Reinhardt will be
dishing scoop on dark Betty so get
excited but for now please give this
video a like and hit the comments to
tell me if you can solve my three clues
oh and for all you thug head fans out
there tell me what you love most about
their relationship and shout out if
you're intrigued by this new TV couples
show I'm teasing I'll be dropping more
secrets soon see ya after the episode
River babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]